we're about to be 25 years in with your
hubby
come on yes that's unheard of in
hollywood
no big anniversary coming up i
there's like a little pressure like i i
need to do something extra
and my husband is usually so good and
plans
the anniversary but i'm like but i gotta
step up my game so
it's yeah it's a big one coming up
i love you i love you do you sit back
and let him just
do whatever he wants to do for you or do
you give hints like
i saw this and this was really nice okay
cool no because he's really good at that
he and that's his love language he loves
those surprises he loves taking care of
and planning
so and i'm easy going that way i'm like
whoa you want to take care of it
you go ahead i'll just enjoy it whatever
it is and there are so many people that
will be screaming at the television
right now like
ask her what her secret is ask her how
they lasted this long so i'm asking
what's the secret to a long-lasting
being 25 years in
man some days you just got to hang in
there
because you're just you're in it and you
got to stay in it you know you don't
want to be in it yeah
you know but it's it's hills and valleys
along the way but
uh man i especially with last year
all of us staying home so much i fell in
love with my husband all over again
we're spending so much time
i remember all the things that i forgot
about
because life has been so busy so if
there's a silver lining
to what to 2020 it's that i really
enjoyed my husband
and my family i love that so much i
haven't heard many people say that the
pandemic was actually good
for their marriage so that's really
that's a good thing you're like i do
like this man i really like this man yes
yes we had to bite yesterday's shower
tonight your friend kathy santoni is
getting married
she's already married she's having a
baby
what she's still in high school i know
she's getting extra credit for it at
home
let me ask you about another man that
you like bob saget who's turning 65 on
the 17th of may do you have a favorite
memory of you guys
like i don't know shooting or just in
life because i know you all are very
close and love each other
i have so many bob saget memories yeah i
mean i have memories of everyone but i'm
so close to bob we've had such a
wonderful friendship over the years but
i would say like immediately it takes me
back to being like
17 years old sitting with him
and scott weinger who played steve on
full house in fuller house
listening to music because bob would be
like so into music
and then i would think that i was really
cool because he would be
like sharing all of these like older
musicians
and their music and then like all the
new current stuff so bob
always felt like he was cooler than us
dj you don't want to live in the garage
it's filthy it's stuffy you want some
fresh air
what do you remember most about that
very first episode i mean i remember
so much of it i remember meeting bob for
the first time because we had already
shot the pilot and then re-shot the
pilot because
bob had come in uh for the the second
time we shot it
and i remember the scene with uncle
jesse like with john stamos in the
in the basement garage oh i there's so
much i remember about it
and who knew now john stamos would be
like the cutest dad
in hollywood i mean seeing him with his
like doesn't it make him even cuter and
sexier than we ever thought he could be
yes except when you've been around him
for so many years you know
how great he is with children and you
always knew he was going to be this
incredible dad
so he's just proving us right yeah and
he loves disney so how could you not be
a good dad when you love disney so much
so we are both speaking at the country
living and good housekeeping first ever
makeover takeover renovation summit i'm
so excited that we get to do this
together first of all
i didn't know that you loved the
renovation space so much
i've learned so much about building
you're like wait a minute
yeah hold on hold on
um i actually do love it but trust me
i'm no
expert yeah uh and i know there's lots
of experts there that are going to give
much better advice than
than i will be able to but i do
love design and i do have my
my product brands that are interior and
home goods and we have actually
renovated two of our homes
from the studs up so i've been through
the process
but i think that's the best thing about
it i'm the same way i'm no expert but
i just finished building one house i
sold it i was very successful at it so i
decided i'm gonna build again so now i'm
in the midst of building from the ground
up again and i think
one of the great things that people that
are doing this summit can can find out
is just like
regular folks who are doing it the
things we did wrong the things we did
right
the things when we do it over we do
differently so i think that's kind of
what
they want to hear is that why you wanted
to participate in this as well yes
absolutely
it's yeah a great i mean it's two days
virtual
you know sit in front of your computer
and get all of this
advice and we still have two rooms in
our home that
need uh to be renovated a little bit i
talked about my
laundry room being in my garage which
there's no laundry room
it's just a washer and dryer in a garage
so
i need to like make that become a space
yeah yeah and see those are the good
things i think those are the good tips
that we're going to get on how to do
those
like at-home hacks that so much of us
are trying to do right now
i'm kind of looking at your background
and i'm trying to see if i can
get your style what would you say your
style
is well it's definitely west coast
uh west coast casual but you know
there's definitely a
mid-century flair to it yes but we've
really taken the elements from the
outside because we're by
the beach and the mountains and we've
tried to
put that inside so it's just it is
cohesive when you walk from the front
door
uh out to the back door that you feel
like you're in a very unified space
with nature you talked about this a
little bit but i do want to say
congratulations on
your new fashion line with qvc here are
the colors it comes in
this is flamingo
oh i'm feeling i need to like flamingo
okay i need to dance
what i love that you did candice is make
sure that you were size inclusive
that's so important why was that
something that you really
said i got to make sure this is how we
roll because god made us in all
different shapes and sizes and i want
everybody to be
able to wear it and feel beautiful and
comfortable
no matter what size you are so we have
everything from petites
and you know double extra small through
5x and i'm doing my best to show
everyone in all sizes and um
i just i love it i'm just happy that no
one's feeling left
out yeah that was very very important do
you see a future in this space for you
and the partnership that you have
now for clothing yeah for clothing yeah
for your clothes
absolutely yeah yeah i mean we debuted
and it sold out
in the day we debuted which was
incredible
and then um you know we just had a
launch
for may and we have another one coming
up at the end of the month
but i love this space it's one that i've
dreamed about for many years so this has
been
years in the making and the partnership
has been well over a few years with qvc
so
we finally got to debut it and i
couldn't be more thrilled well when it's
authentic to you we feel it so that's
why like it sold out so much because
people knew that like it was authentic
to you
thank you i every everything i do
[Music]
you